avec moi sur ce plateau nicolas
kirillovitch bonsoir bonsoir la
rédaction de tv 70 on va se poser avec
vous une question est ce que c'est le
début d'un divorce entre les yvelines et
autolib le système d'autopartage est la
cible de nombreuses critiques est depuis
plusieurs mois dans le département les
collectivités qui proposent le service
s'inquiète notamment du déficit de cet
équipement géré par le groupe bolloré
alors ces collectivités ont décidé
nicolas de se faire entendre
en effet et pour bien comprendre l'enjeu
du problème commençons par un chiffre
celui qui va s'afficher sur l'écran 179
millions d'euros ce n'est pas le chiffre
d'affaires est généré par le service
autolib' met son déficit prévu à
l'horizon 2023 selon des informations du
groupe bolloré vous le disais qu'ils
gèrent autolib depuis 2011
et c'est se chiffre précisément qui a
semé le trouble auprès des collectivités
territoriales du département puisque le
groupe bolloré s'engage à payer
seulement une partie de cette dette 60
millions d'euros
il resterait alors à la charge des
villes adhérentes 119 millions d'euros à
régler et selon des informations parues
dans la presse resam récemment en fait
ce déficit pourrait même atteindre 250
millions d'euros ce qui rajoute
évidemment de l'inquiétude à
l'inquiétude est d'ailleurs nicolas ce
déficit pousse les communes à réfléchir
sur leur investissement
oui depuis un an maintenant beaucoup
d'entre elles font marche arrière la
ville de bois d'arcy par exemple a
décidé de ne plus installer du tout deux
stations sur son territoire alors que la
première devait être inaugurée à cette
année la ville de versailles elle
ralentit les investissements
neuf stations sont prévues initialement
à elle se limite à 5 pour le moment et
l'agglomération de 50 ans divine et est
aussi concernée elle a décidé de stopper
les installations pour l'instant à la
base 26 stations sont prévues sur le
territoire tout est prêt selon les
services de l'agglomération
mais rien n'est déployée au regard
justement des risques financiers
fermez les guillemets un constat négatif
est ce qu'il est possible pour autolib
d'inverser cette tendance
eh bien oui selon les élus
linois justement et notamment philippe
brillault le maire l'est républicain de
la ville du chesnay qui a pris en
quelque sorte la fronde 1 de 7 de la
faune locale sa ville était la première
initialement à avoir installé autolib
dans les yvelines
et il demande une réorganisation de la
stratégie d'autolib pour lui il faut
davantage communiquer pour attirer plus
d'utilisateurs arrêté aussi la chasse à
la voiture lancée par la mairie de paris
selon un philippe brillault et valoriser
aussi le service autolib face à la
concurrence des vtc ou des taxis et
surtout philippe brillault souhaite plus
de transparence pour connaître les vrais
problèmes d'autolib un petit exemple un
audit a été lancé il ya neuf mois
les résultats ne sont toujours pas
connues à l'heure selon philippe
brillault il en va de la survie
d'autolib écoutez le la direction
d'origine tel qu'il a été prévu de la
délégation initial qui n'était faite que
pour la ville de paris ne va plus dans
le bon sens et donc comme toutes
nouvelles choses mais il faut la
réactualiser c'est ce que je demande
c'est ce que nous demandons et je suis
bien déterminé à mobiliser l'ensemble
des communes qui partagent mon point de
vue sur le sujet voire même des élus de
paris qui devront se réveiller
s'interroger et se mobiliser je dis
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une urgence et en
tant que médecin je sais que les
urgences sont importantes sinon elles
ont des conséquences létale et grégory
une mauvaise nouvelle n'arrive jamais
seule pour la première fois en l'espace
de cinq ans les abonnements autolib sont
en baisse entre 2017 et 2016 - 5 % pour
atteindre aujourd'hui un peu plus de 103
mille abonnements actifs
merci nicolas pour ces précisions